Good morning, good evening, and good afternoon.
I am Strony Cuttles, and before you say a thing, yes, I'm f***ing Scottish.
Then, before you say the second thing, yes, I'm a cuttlefish, that's why I'm called Cuttles.
Then, for the third thing, because I'm Scottish, I don't say the double T's in the middle of Cuttles,
and thus I can never say my name correctly.
Phew.
Now that we've got that out of the way, do you like ASMR?
Do you like shameless people?
Do you like filthy degenerates that don't know how to go offline and will ruin your sleep pattern?
Good, because that might be the answer to your prayers.
Well, June 1st, I'll be waiting on you.
So stop squiddin' around and be there.